when I was younger I was really angry at
my parents like many people are
Justified or not doesn't really matter I
was very angry and I blamed them for the
woes of my life I realized when I was 19
that these people that I hated I was
giving all the power over the fact that
I wasn't the person I wanted to be and I
was like well it's their fault the idea
that I had actually given these people
that I hated Power Over My Success was
ultimately something that made me feel
sick to my stomach and was what allowed
me to point the finger of blame inwards
and say my fault and then at least take
ownership over the fact that like and
like sure maybe your dad didn't hug you
enough or maybe your mom wasn't present
or whatever it is right it's like and